[Musik]
hallo ich sehe hier auf der baustelle
heute gibt's einen baustellen update
denn ich finde er war schon lang nicht
mehr mühe auf der baustelle hinter mir
seht ihr es kommen also fängt an wie ein
richtiges haus aus zu sehen
das letzte mal hatten wir ja im
erdgeschoss und paar wände schon hat mir
die chance hatten wir schon und jetzt
haben wir die decke schon drauf die
decke haben vor ein paar wochen und zwar
wurde sie angeliefert und dann wurden
die deckenplatten einfach schön drauf
gesetzt und mittlerweile sind wir schon
mit der hälfte des obergeschosses fertig
das heißt wir machen jetzt eine haustür
sanierer und murat warten schon oben und
ich würde mal sagen wir fangen im
erdgeschoss unten an
ob ich für euch einmal rum kommt man mit
stück gefahr
hier im vorderen bereich sind wir schon
in meiner vielen küche hier denke ich
wow ist wie groß sie ist groß wir haben
ja auch eine deckenhöhe von drei meter
fünfzig und deswegen weil wir immer
viele kameras aufstellen zusammen für
den licht da will ich da kommt auf 100
decke herunter so dass wir uns einfach
das auf und abbauen immer sparen können
und einfach jeden tag eine stunde mehr
zeit haben um zu filmen
daher die deckenhöhe und natürlich auch
der raum da wir jetzt zu hause bei uns
gerade ein bisschen eingeschränkt sind
ich mein ich arbeite mit zwei bis vier
kameras und das heißt alles steht immer
voll und alles ist sehr eng und wir
müssen immer wieder umstellen während
dem dreh und es lohnt sich hier einfach
nichts das heißt hier können wir alles
stehen lassen
ich kann hier drüben zum beispiel dann
ein foto tisch aufstellen und direkt die
gerichte die ich gekocht habe auch super
fotografieren
so hat es momentan nicht so dass wir
immer so ein kleines fotostudio in
meiner küche aufbauen
und ja man einfach den vorteil dass
wirklich sehr sehr viel zeit sparen kann
hier kommt dann also meine küche rein
und hier vorne ist schon so ein bereich
wahrscheinlichen ex ist um auch hin und
können uns dann hier immer alles
zusammen doch mittagessen
jetzt gehen wir nach hinten hier hinter
mir wenn ihr durchlauf das seht ihr die
herren und damen verletzungen rechts und
links und dann gehts jetzt durch wird
und wann büroräume das heißt hier ist im
büro sei schon groß büro da haben die
jungs und mädels platz und videos zu
schneiden fotos zu bearbeiten wir können
und wir besprechen und gemeinsame
aktionen planen und es findet dann alles
hier statt
dann geht's hier weiter hier ist auch
unser lager das heißt da können wir noch
alles verstauen was wir zum beispiel mit
auf die messe nehmen wobei dadurch nicht
ausreichen wird aber wir gucken einfach
mal das ist auch recht wenn ich aber
noch die garage und können da mit sachen
verstauen und hier gehts dann einfach
weiter zu meinen eltern nach oben und
hinten gibt weiter zur garage
ich finde sich das ganze schon bis ins
vorstellen das heißt das ganze wirklich
gestalt angenommen und jetzt schauen wir
uns den rohbau ist fertig das heißt die
mauern stehen die decken sind da hier
seht ihr in der ecke zum beispiel auch
schon
die ganzen leerrohre wird mein bruder
hingelegt denn mein bruder macht die
ganze elektrik im haus und nach dem
rohbau kommt auch der part von meinem
bruder das heißt er muss sich an zu
bewahren
die ganzen installationen machen gibt
werden auch demnächst an die heizungen
geliefert wie bekommen überall
zufriedenheit und das wird dann eben
alles nicht im anschluss gemacht wir
fangen wir von vorne einfach mal ganz
kurz durch das habt ihr alles schon
gesehen aber die ganzen stützen weg und
können von anschauen
ich glaube ich hab dir einen
feuerwehrmann stange dann kann man immer
vom obergeschoss einfach runter rutschen
nach dem aufstehen einfach so direkt in
die küche und nicht verletzt
hier geht's dadurch den vorab frau und
ich hab hier platz 17 kilo zucker und
zehn kilometer ich habe immer dann
freeport weil ich immer mache und was
dann kommt man direkt in die küche reihe
einfach kurze wege vom laufen das
flüchtige auf den einkauf einfach in die
vorratskammer von der vorratskammer dann
in die küche
hier wird noch was verändert und zwar
wird die mauer entfernt
sie wollte eigentlich von anfang an ist
aber da hat der statiker unsere probleme
gemacht das heißt wir mussten dann die
mauer doch noch einziehen
ihr zimmer eine lösung gefunden die
mauer kommt weg und kommt einfach
unterstützen und gefällt mir persönlich
dann einfach besser
angeln gehen und dann habe ich einfach
ein zimmer wohnzimmer und küche
verbunden so dass wirklich alles ein
großer raum wird und das will ich
sondern auch das schön
wir haben jetzt gerade kurz vor mittag
das heißt die mittagssonne kommt auch
schöne reihen hat immer viel licht und
hier hat mich eigentlich zum letzten mal
nicht verändert dass ich weiterhin
büroraum
hier ist weiterhin die toilette mit dem
zu großen fenster für den rovers aber
das noch kleine gebracht damit da eben
nicht auffällt gucken und zu einer auf
der toilette ja dann kann man im sind
wieder nach hinten und über die bag
hatte also übers treppenhaus meiner
eltern
peugeot hat
was treppe aus meiner eltern einfach
kurz nach oben
ja meinen betontreppe genommen
rettungstreppe deswegen weil die etwas
günstiger ist als eine stahltreppe und
was ich hier ganz praktisch wenn die
scheint das ist ja nur ein kartenhaus
und deswegen haben wir uns ein bisschen
platz hier sind ja auch relativ kühl das
heißt wir haben keine keller und haben
sich zwar schon kleine möglichkeit jetzt
lebensmittel kühl zu lagern und meine
mama besteht eigentlich von steam ist
raus deswegen habe ich mir gedacht dass
du hier unterwegs habe den platz nutzen
und hier schränke einbauen wird dann
hier alles schön rein gegangen als er
überlege ich noch ein system aber das
gefällt mir so schon ganz gut mit dem
iran nach oben geht jetzt sind wir hier
oben
also für mich könnte jetzt immer so
bleiben schön hell aber natürlich auch
noch mit deckel drauf kleidung hier
vorne ist der bereich meiner eltern da
wird es nächste woche noch gebaut und
sich in dem bereich euch schon mal
zeigen und zu meinen eltern können wir
dann praktisch über das dach laufen also
über das geraten doch über die
dachterrasse kümmern dann einfach
überlaufen kann es natürlich bei uns
ganz praktisch wir können dann am
wochenende und unter der woche auch mal
es morgen früh zusammen frühstücken und
am wochenende eben hier richtig schön
frisch
das mag ich auch total mit meinen eltern
[Musik]
hier weise die tür von der dachterrasse
zu uns nach hause und hier den bereich
seht ihr hier kommt unsere treppe hin
das heißt vom untergeschoss vom eingang
nach oben ins obergeschoss also unten
haben wir dann praktisch diesen wohnraum
wohn essbereich und küche und oben dann
die schlafräume hier links haben wir die
waschküche also das wort
hauswirtschaftsraum den habe ich nicht
im erdgeschoss von man im obergeschoss
weil wir auch hier die schlafräume haben
das heißt hier ziehen wir uns auf den
wir uns um die ganze welt kann dann hier
rein und dann eben auch die
waschmaschine und das ist dann ganz
praktisch hier drüben haben wir jetzt
unser gemeinsames familienbad also sieht
jetzt alles ein bisschen groß aus es
gebe ich echt so aber erst überlegen wir
wohnen hier meine eltern wohnen hier wir
arbeiten hier
das heißt wir sind hier immer minimum
zehn personen und von daher brauchen wir
schon den ganzen platz und vor allem für
die mitarbeiter damit leben alle von
arbeiten können aber eben auch hier
leben können und so alles wirklich
miteinander verbinden können
und hier kann direkt durchs badezimmer
ins schlafzimmer finde ich auch immer
ganz praktisch und hier werden wir dann
einbauschränke machen weil ich das ganz
praktisch finde dass man keine schränke
hat sie eben oben staub fläche bieten
das heißt alles geht bis an die decke
hier haben wir auch nur zwei meter
fünfzig deckenhöhe also eine ganz
normale deckenhöhe und es erkennt man
dann wenn da eben nächste woche dann die
decke drauf kommt dann kann man sich das
alles noch mal richtig vorstellen weiter
geht's zu den kindern die kinderzimmer
die sind wir gegenüber
das heißt hier hat von ihrer erst die
zweite mal sind auch gleich groß das
heißt wenn beide 18 quadratmeter groß
einziger unterschied familie hat ihren
ex fenster und da hat sie dann halt noch
so kleinen von kleinen balkon davor
jetzt das frische haben wir noch ein
kleines war das heißt hier kommt dann
raten mit dusche und waschbecken und
toilette können die kinder einfach zu
unserem nutzen und hier drüben haben wir
noch elastisch
ich freue mich schon darauf in alles
passiert und ich habe noch einen raum
und zwar ist es unser gästezimmer
wir haben echt oft besucht das heißt
meine schwester zum beispiel wohnt nicht
weit weg die wohnt in richtung aachen
sie kann dann hier wohnen
oder und freundes haben verdiene offen
vom online shop
die wohnen auch in oberndorf am neckar
und wenn die untersuchen schlafend auch
gerne bei uns
das heißt gäste haben wir immer zu hause
deswegen haben wir hier ein gästezimmer
und werden dann eben auch einrichten
sodass einfach platt ist und wir immer
gäste in empfang nehmen können
jetzt geht es an die arbeit jetzt werden
wir hier die mauern hochziehen bei
meiner mama und wir haben die außenwände
auslieferungen aus das heißt wir müssen
später das haus nicht stimmen da der
übung stein wirklich sehr gut isoliert
wie ihre bänder machen wir allerdings
auf filter kalksandstein wird auch der
steinbinder murat herstellers morassi
wirklich quasi mitgewirkt und die
kalksandsteine nehmen wir deswegen weil
es einfach verschiedene vorteile haben
das heißt man hat mit guten schallschutz
was ihnen im raum schon wirklich sehr
wichtig ist man kann wirklich schwerste
schränke dranhängen das heißt man kann
gut born und stuben und was auch ganz
wichtig ist ist die wärmespeicherung das
kennt ihr vielleicht von europa oder von
der oma die haben früher auch immer ganz
schwere steine in den ofen
reingeschmissen haben sie aufgewärmt und
dann mit ins bett genommen und sich
daran später zu kuscheln sind sie
speichern die wärme und geben sie dann
ganz langsam wieder ab damit die
kalksandsteine der einzige nachteil für
mich die kalkscheune sind etwas schwerer
als die übung steine die wirklich sehr
leicht in die masse gut hochheben kann
aber auch das schaffe ich hier findet im
treppenhaus die erste sieg wurde schon
gemacht und zwar auf die karte und war
deswegen um die unebenheiten am boden
einfach auszugleichen
das heißt die erste schrift muslime eine
torte ist und richtig gerade sein wenn
wir nehmen so uneben ist wie die ganze
torte schlief das heißt die ganze wand
wirklich und nicht eben jetzt nämlich
ein simples module also dem kleber und
dem fraglich es auf das ist im prinzip
wie beim torte backen in der kabine
die creme erstmal braucht reichlich und
das heilen
und dann klappt und die feine selten
wissen schwerer als regierungs feine
aber selbst das steuer und dann hat man
hier für führungs- und feder kann es
hier ansatzlosen und einfach runter
gleiten lassen
von mir aus um arbeit und sie durfte
hier eben auch kleber auf fragen jetzt
machte die steine wieder sauber und
damit wieder kleber aufgetragen
[Musik]
und den überschüssigen mittel nämlich
einfach mit der kelle weckt oder bei mir
in der küche zeigen
der winkel palette
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und wenn mal ein schwein zu große summen
mit kleinen lücke aber kann man den ganz
einfach mit der säge zu erteilen
[Musik]
erstens nicht für euch erledigt jetzt
machen wir weiter und ich hab jetzt
nicht länger als drei minuten gebraucht
für eine lade einfach mal vergibt
[Musik]
wir haben fleißig gemauert und jetzt
machen wir nicht gleich feierabend
der hintere teil hier also der bereich
meine eltern er wird jetzt kommende
woche noch gemauert das heißt innerhalb
von vier bis fünf tagen war die moral
mein bruder mein papa diesem teil der
mauer
es geht wirklich super schnell und ja da
ging es wirklich schon sehr gespannt auf
die decke kommt dann noch drauf und dann
nimmt das ganze schon gestalt an
mein bruder macht man die raw
installationen und verlangsamt wird das
haus fertig also eigentlich von juli bis
september einziehen aber ich glaube dass
offengelegt haben wir jetzt schon april
und von daher müsse man einfach mal
schauen wie schnell es geht jedenfalls
von ihrer würde ich sagen wir zwei haben
heute genug gearbeitet
wir machen jetzt feierabend gehen gleich
auf dem spielplatz und vorher wäre mir
noch eine räuberleiter also zunächst
nochmals hin
leider sei hoch
[Musik]
wir waren mit super